como será que seria o google se em vez
de oferecer respostas oferecesse
perguntas primeira vez que a negação
veemente
foi quando recebi o convite para dar o
que achei que seria um curso de
liderança para jovens das comunidades
ribeirinhas da floresta amazônica
do alto da minha prepotência de alguém
vindo de uma região economicamente
privilegiada
eu achei que teria muito o que ensinar
pra esses jovens mas o que aconteceu foi
exatamente o contrário quando começou a
coletar mais informações sobre o estilo
de vida deles e como que era viver numa
comunidade ribeirinha no meio da
amazônia
eu percebi que nada absolutamente nada
que eu sabia sobre liderança
seria útil para eles da maneira como eu
pelo menos não acostumado a lidar com o
termo só para dar um exemplo
vários deles pegaram quatro dias de
barco para participar desse encontro
e para piorar sete dias de volta porque
a volta contra a correnteza do rio do
rio juruá
o que a gente fez então foi inverter o
processo em vez de aula pergunta em vez
de ensinar e aprender com elas e com
eles o que a gente fez foi adaptar uma
metodologia que era baseada em perguntas
em três na verdade a primeira delas era
perguntar o que há de bom aqui na
comunidade de vocês vão apreciar um
pouco que já tem aqui para aí sim poder
fazer a segunda pergunta que é qual é o
sonho que vocês têm as suas comunidades
e termina perguntando e agora o que
vocês vão fazer para que estes se tornem
reais
a gente terminou fazendo duas atividades
com eles na primeira entregou folhas de
cartolina e pediu pra que desenhassem
como seriam as comunidades
quando o som estivesse sendo realizados
e o que a gente imaginava que era
parecido com o centro urbano ou algo do
tipo mas o mais interessante é que na
cartolina inteira uma coisa nova conta
quero verde
em vez de prédios ou asfaltos a
comunidade exatamente como ela é com uma
edição como por exemplo uma escola ou um
laboratório de informática ou um posto
de saúde para que não precisassem mais
ter que viajar três quatro horas de
barco para estudar para aprender ou para
tratar alguma enfermidade oab pra mim no
entanto foi quando fez uma rodada de
entrevistas tipo um talk show e chamou
uma menina de 11 anos de idade e uma das
perguntas fez para ela foi o que você
quer ser quando você crescer e ela
respondeu muito sinceramente eu quero
ser uma advogada advogada que legal
porque aí no semblante muito único ela
virou e falou assim em falar uma vez que
é advogado ganha muito dinheiro só
continua mas não é por isso quero ser
advogada
eu quero ser advogada para poder
defender a minha floresta
a maneira como é como como ela respondeu
mexeu com a gente e fez refletir em
muita coisa assim porque talvez nem todo
mundo esteja tão conectado com o seu
ambiente da maneira como ela eu por
exemplo nunca vi a minha cidade da
maneira como ela via a floresta dela mas
talvez nem todo mundo esteja tão
conectado com a sua própria comunidade
com as pessoas ao seu redor e talvez nem
todo mundo já está conectado com si
mesmo capaz de ter consciência
suficiente para compreender o seu
propósito no meio disso tudo
o problema porém não é tão visível essa
nossa falta de às vezes questionar de
fazer perguntas faz com que a gente
entre em modo automático e acaba se
acostumando muito mais com o como as
coisas são em vez de explorar a beleza
do como as coisas poderiam ser agora o
fato de não fazer tanta pergunta pode
parecer às vezes preguiça falta de
motivação falta de energia ou algo do
tipo mas sinceramente acredito que isso
na verdade é uma renúncia é a renúncia
de acreditar que dá pra ser melhor e que
agora nesse
momento tem novas verdades flutuando
entre nós um dos seus preferidos para
isso muito bem e se chama doze homens e
uma sentença para fazer uma sinopse
rápida é 12 homens compõem o júri
popular e precisam decidir o destino de
um menino de 18 anos acusado de matar o
próprio pai
dos 12 11 tem certeza convicção de que
ele é culpado e querendo condenar a
cadeira elétrica ir embora pra casa só
que desses 12 um deles ainda têm dúvidas
e ele faz perguntas que provocam os
outros a pensarem e muda todo o destino
de uma história que poderia culminar com
a morte de um jovem inocente
a grande questão aqui para poder fazer
essas perguntas certas e muitas vezes o
ambiente no ambiente são muito pouco
férteis para receber perguntas certas
alguns passos anteriores são
interessantes serem feitos
o primeiro deles é que a gente consiga
criar vulnerabilidade um determinado
grupo para que a gente tenha empatia com
o modelo mental porque eles têm empatia
com o modelo mental determinado grupo a
gente tem a segurança de poder
desconstruir a certeza que a gente tem
para aí sim abrir espaço às reais
dúvidas para poder fazer as perguntas
certas
mas será que a gente faz isso bem quando
por exemplo uma criança curiosa pergunta
por quê por quê porque a gente tem
paciência responde por que não
quanto eu estimo que está dando para que
ela seja uma boa pergunta a dora e
queira de fato questionar o que está
acontecendo o que acaba levando que
acaba acontecendo com isso tudo é que a
gente começa a sofrer estímulos receber
estímulos para parar de perguntar e
quando eu paro de perguntar eu começo a
me reservar o meu mundo ao meu
individualismo esqueça também de
perguntar quem são as pessoas que estão
aqui o meu redor
o que se pode fazer então é continuar
perguntando fazer um esforço da pergunta
e o mais interessante
é que não necessariamente eles vão ser
realizadas quando a gente tem
consciência do significado da nossa ação
a nossa ação é a nossa pergunta por
exemplo um bom projeto de urbanismo
pode ser na verdade uma pergunta como é
que eu faço para que as pessoas
interajam mais e melhor os espaços
públicos uma escola inovadora pode ser
uma pergunta como é que eu faço pra que
seres humanos sejam formados como seres
humanos ou mais do que isso como é que
um maluco
pode perguntar qual o problema de
abraçam estranho
já tá fazendo aqui hoje inclusive o mais
interessante é que quando a gente começa
a fazer perguntas quando começa a
perguntar algo sobre você e como colocar
no seu lugar eu começo a entender a sua
perspectiva de um mundo melhor ainda
começa a entender qual é o seu mundo
uma coisa interessante e que houve uma
vez é que a gente não vê o mundo como
ele é mundo é como a gente vê e quando
se consegue compreender melhor a visão
de outras pessoas
isso começa a acontecer de maneira muito
mais eficaz mais do que benevolência
isso nos confere mais inteligência para
poder resolver problemas que são
complexos que tem causa e efeito
distantes um do outro e te aproxima isso
com a nossa própria aproximação e para
poder fazer isso três passos podem ser
muito interessantes
primeiro a gente precisa se conectar e
se conectar
é muito simples é ficar vulnerável é
poder falar não sei é poder querer saber
quem é você poder poder perguntar por
que oprah que porque quando a gente
consegue fazer isso em criar um ambiente
de questionamento
as dúvidas que vem elas vêm junto com
uma dose enorme de humildade que quando
se faz as perguntas certas na verdade
quem está fazendo é considerar a
hipótese de está errado
hoje está com informações incompletas
porque quando eu admito que estou errado
com informações completas aí sim talvez
eu tenha consciência suficiente para
provocar uma ação minha
hoje a comunidade inteira vítor franco
disse uma vez que uma pessoa tira tudo
você só não tira o último tipo de
liberdade que a liberdade da escolha é a
liberdade da própria atitude é liberdade
construiu seu próprio caminho
independente das circunstâncias e esse
processo de facilitar a criação de
perguntas
ele na verdade é um processo de
libertação porque quando eu faço a
pergunta certa quando a gente se faz a
pergunta certa o que está fazendo é
abrir espaço para a escolha porque eu só
escolho algo quando pergunto algo que é
fato consumado que a gente enquanto
espécie sempre se mover por perguntas
que permitiram a gente sobreviver e
evoluir
isso não é novidade a grande questão é
que talvez a gente esteja um
desequilíbrio de ter muita resposta que
as respostas são cada vez mais
acessíveis em cada vez mais quantidade e
elas em geral vêm de fora e as perguntas
cada vez mais escassas que elas demandam
um nível de energia que está se
acostumando principalmente porque ela
vem de dentro
e é esse desequilíbrio que preocupa
muita gente por isso que o meu apelo
para que continue perguntando continuei
perguntando porque em algum momento a
coisa vai acontecer
miguel cavalcanti falou a frase muito
legal falou que quando a gente tem todas
as respostas que vão mudar as perguntas
só que acima de tudo fazer boas
perguntas na verdade faz de nós
excelentes líderes capaz de ver o mundo
com outros olhos e fico pensando que
talvez a gente não precise de mais dados
mais informação até mesmo mais
conhecimento mais conhecimento
simplesmente novos olhos que permitam a
gente vê o que ninguém viu e perguntar o
que ninguém perguntou
as respostas portanto elas são que uma
foto do presente mas se o presente está
em constante mudança do que elas servem
e talvez seja isso
as respostas são descartáveis as
perguntas são reaproveitadas
a resposta já é um conforto
as perguntas eram consciência e as
perguntas eram ação ao mesmo tempo é um
dilema ele tem que admitir eu tenho que
perguntar o seguinte trecho em frente
importante e da senso de realização o
que me permite fazer alguma coisa é
seguir em frente mas a gente abraça a
liberdade de fazer pergunta na verdade
está abraçando a liberdade da escolha ea
liberdade da escolha ela provoca um
movimento incrível que tirar a gente da
posição de vítima e passagem de uma
posição de protagonista e se isso parece
interessante para o indivíduo imagina o
poder que isso tem para a organização o
que a comunidade inteira esse poder vai
muito além da nossa compreensão isso é
muito mais do que racional isso é muito
mais que cartesiano
a grande questão então é saber
exatamente qual o momento certo para
perguntar porque talvez é isso que vamos
conferir a sabedoria de entender se é o
momento de perguntar ou se é o momento
de seguir em frente e é por isso que eu
queria terminar com uma fábula que
começa exatamente uma pergunta entre um
pastor um esquilo um dia um pastor
chegou por skylar grey falou esquilo
você com toda sua sabedoria me responda
uma coisa quanto pesa um floco de neve
que respondeu nada mais que nada e passa
o troco sério então senta aí eu quero te
contar uma coisa aconteceu comigo ontem
o pastor falou de um galho tam começou a
levar
tá vendo nada mesmo resolvi contar
quando os flocos de neve a cair em cima
daquele galho e eu contei 2 milhões
999999 floco de neve e como cada floco
de neve não fazer nada nada mais que
nada nada aconteceu
só que o pastor falou caiu o flávio 3
milhões e quando caiu o número 3 milhões
o galo se partiu e caiu no chão esquerdo
a i4i daí eu fiquei pensando e se o
mundo inteiro já tiver feito o seu
movimento e só esperando meu tá com
grande movimento de vida
e ele continuou esse só faltará a minha
mudança para que eu de fato vejo o mundo
da maneira que eu quero aquela menina da
amazônia era um floco de neve
mesmo sem saber assim como cada um de
nós aqui e é a esperança de que
terminando aqui já é continuar se
perguntando sempre que também terminou
com essa pergunta e se só falta você
obrigado